in 2005 New York City firefighter Avid
marathoner and Ironman athlete Matt long
hopped onto his bike and basically did
what he did every day ride from his
Manhattan apartment to the Randalls
Island fire academy where he helped
train the city's bravest but as he
crossed 52nd Street a 20-ton bus made a
sudden right turn from the Middle Lane
and struck Matt head on dragging his
body underneath where Matt was quite
literally impaled by his bike
Matt ended up spending the next month in
a coma and when he woke up his doctors
told him he was facing a one percent
chance of survival but Matt my friends
had other plans today's rollback episode
highlights this incredible and harrowing
audio-only conversation from February of
2015 where Matt unpacks the story of his
accident of his recovery and of his
comeback quest to tackle the 2008 New
York City marathon just three years
after waking from his coma a story well
told in his beautiful Memoir the long
run
Matt is a man I hold in high regard uh
just an incredible example of the
resiliency not just of the physical body
but of the emotional body the
indomitable boundless strength of the
human spirit in selfless service to
others so please hit that subscribe
button and I sincerely hope you enjoy
this exchange between me and Matt long
what is a what's a typical day look like
for you now
typical day for me
um
is waking up at six and taking the dogs
out and then tending to my two-year-old
yeah so and getting the older ones off
to school but uh
after nine o'clock everything kind of
settles down wife goes to work and um
and I'm back into training or or doing
what I you know whatever I can for the
day
uh-huh and uh you know we were talking a
little bit
um before we started recording about how
you know our lives are are very
different
um they're on they're sort of on
different paths but there's these
they're sort of common themes and and uh
and they intersect in different ways
like I sort of you know created This
Disaster for myself to have to look in
the mirror and kind of change my ways
and live a different life and and you
had a you know a tragic intervening
event but it set you on a different kind
of path for your life and I think that's
that's super interesting
yeah
um you know you never know what uh
when you choose the road you're going to
take in life you never know what's going
to happen and
um you know I guess it's an old additive
when I go around talking about it I just
it's what you do after that event that
um that changes who you are yeah for
sure I mean something like that you have
two choices right it's either gonna it's
gonna Crush you it's gonna break you or
you have an opportunity to learn from it
and grow and and share something from
that and you obviously chose the latter
but it's the struggle and the journey
towards that choice I think where uh you
know where where your message is so
powerful
yeah you know and that and that struggle
and that Journey
um
what was not easy you know it um it's
funny I can go around and talk about I
can laugh about I can make some jokes
about different things now
but um
but those let's say two years
of um depression and surgeries and and
you know fighting different weaknesses
in my body
um
it's you know it just felt like it was a
more than two years like a lifetime you
know this they like there were multiple
multiple times where I said to myself I
can't do this you know and and and
you're right you either just quit
and it takes you
or you fight
and uh you know I'm not I don't think
I've had any kind of level of success in
winning the battle because I'm not who I
used to be and I never will I'll never
run as fast as I did I you know I'll
never cycle I'll never be as strong
uh physically as I was but uh but
but I'm living my life the best I can
and that's there's no there's not no
beating that well I think if you if you
take a more expansive uh definition of
strength you're a stronger person now
you may not be able to run as fast as
you could but I think in terms of
overall strength I would I would
characterize you as as now being an
extremely strong person
you know it's funny we segue to that
because uh
two of men's fitness men in the world
sitting in one room in the same room at
the same time unbelievable we should
call Men's Fitness and tell them that's
right yes Rich and Matt are doing a
push-up contest right yeah right it was
uh I think it was you were 2010 in that
one right were you or is it that every
man like hero kind of thing because
that's the what they that's how they
pigeonholed me into that I think it was
a year I was 2009 that was a year before
you I think 2010 was me and they just
numbered the amount of surgeries I had
and said that's why he's here yeah good
man yeah it's cool and I'd take it and
roll with it yeah hey man listen you
know what I always say I was like not
for one second do I believe that I'm one
of the 25 fittest men in the world but
that's pretty effective when you're
trying to sell a book
that's a good tagline absolutely right
um but I think you know one question
that comes to mind you know when you're
sort of talking about how it was a hard
Road and such a struggle
you know I'm sure people say to you
every day like oh you're such an
inspiration you know thank you for your
message and all of that like how do you
receive that like when you look back on
your you know sort of the humanity of of
that journey and how difficult it was
for you like how do you process that
you know there are times when um and
there are times when I get told that and
I embrace it and I enjoy it and that is
my finish line that is my sense of
accomplishment or my purpose now and I
really really you know I really take
Summit from something from it like you
were a kid when you know they said wow
what a game you played today great game
you know great job today good effort
and then there are other times
when the person is delivering it to me
is worse off than I was
um
and may never walk again or you know
lost a leg or lost two legs and they
tell me I read your story
and
you inspire me not to quit not to give
up and at that point
I I look at my wife or I looked at
someone close and I thought you know I
don't want to be
this inspiration this is hard you know
this is tough because I'm leaving here
and I'm feeling bad for this person
um and he's looking at me like you know
you're my this is it I'm pushing because
of you and he may never walk again you
know and I have plenty of friends now
because of this journey
two or three that I'm really close with
that are still in wheelchairs
and
you know they let me know that I've
inspired them and I I'm never going to
tell them not to give up their dreams of
walking again I think deep down they may
know it
but their inspiration
to live a good life came from me not
quitting and and I I taught that's
that's the hardest part that's right
when you see someone who who's overcome
it and and moved on awesome I'm glad I
helped you
when you see someone that
is worse than I was
it's very very challenging to to want to
take that role
how often are you uh going out and doing
public speaking and you know what what
does that look like for you now I I've
been uh I've been traveling about 12 16
12 to 16 times a year wow so not too bad
the last three years
um you know this is speaking season is
coming up so things are rolling around
yeah
um but uh yeah you know I take one I
have I do it because I need it for a
living now
and um but I like certain audiences
better than others because I feel like
the message is more received so I really
enjoy speaking to college athletes I
really speak high school athletes a
certain level my story is pretty
gruesome I think for younger kids
um what about veterans
uh I haven't spoken to any veteran group
that's surprising I would I would have
thought that
you would be somebody who would be great
for that yeah I haven't spoken to any
veteran groups I've helped personally or
been involved on this on the background
of helping some veterans I really enjoy
that
um the sacrifice they made and you know
I mean I I guess you could say I
paralleled it by being a firefighter I
knew there was a chance in life that
something really bad could happen to me
right with my profession I didn't think
it would be on a bicycle get into my
work yeah the irony of that is amazing
right like it just it happens in in such
a different way than you would have
predicted you know if it had happened as
a result of you doing your job that's
one thing but
the context in which that occurred is so
is so extraordinary so let's take it
back for for people who may not have
read your book or are not familiar with
your story
um you grew up
a bunch of Brothers in Brooklyn
firefighter like set the stage a little
bit yeah okay so the second oldest of
nine children if uh six brothers and two
sisters
um you know I like to joke about it is
you know Where'd I get my competitive
Natures but dinner on Friday night mom
dad had a small ice cream bottle mom
didn't work how could you work with nine
children back in the day so um yeah so I
think dinner on Friday night was like a
competitive event first one and guess
that's the best best meal
um that's kind of like a firehouse oh
absolutely yeah absolutely
um
and so I become a firefighter after
college and um finding my way in Wall
Street really wasn't for me and I my
dad's like hey you know just take this
test in high school you say take this
test you need to have a backup plan and
I'm like uh you know when you're 18
you're like well who needs a plan yeah I
don't need a plan dad but you listen to
mine I took the test and they called
thank God because I was that point was
out of work and um
and it was like the first time in my
life I was like wow I I loved it I loved
the job and I felt like wow without
knowing without really growing up saying
I'm I was called To Be A New York City
fireman uh it became my calling and I
really enjoyed it enjoyed going to work
every day it was it was just
unbelievable however
it took me down this journey
um
that
that changed
eventually when I realized it changed
the way I operated in life changed the
way I went about my daily routines I got
overweight you know much like your story
you know in the fire department it's a
boys club and every night was a party I
mean guy got promoted you had a party
guys retiring you have a party
you know guys getting divorced let's
have a party right right so plus a bunch
of guys making food for themselves
there's not going to be on the healthy
tip right no no no put another stick of
butter in yeah yeah do you know have you
ever met rip esselstand you know uh
Engine 2 Diet guy oh no no I turned
around yeah yeah so Arizona or uh in
Austin in Austin yeah yeah
um a long story short on on that
bringing my uh
what we're talking about here to to time
um
I started looking doing this inventory
checking my life that's why I like to
talk about it I saw that you know why is
my back hurting why am I not as happy
going to work anymore why am I not doing
this how old were you at that time um
about 35 36 all right I'm 28 pounds
overweight
um you know things are changing and if I
ask guys are getting younger stronger
bigger uh
uh I found running you know I was an
athlete my whole life but I found
running now and now I there was nothing
that could clear your head better than a
60 Minute run in the park you know
you didn't need anything you know it
wasn't as complicated it is today like
who you have your goose what do you have
what are you doing what pills you're
using you know we just went out and ran
and uh well it should be that way now
anyway but that's a different
conversation yeah
um so anyway I started getting into
Endurance Sports triathlons and and
running and making every race count and
all this stuff and and lo and behold
them I started using my bicycle as my
means of transportation mm-hmm and um it
was Christmas time nine years ago
and uh
the New York City Transit Authority
decided to go on strike
shut the city down millions of tourists
no one can get around the city was
jam-packed and I had I was like 18
degrees
I got on my bike and I wasn't that
strong of a person 18 degrees
I was getting in my car right but just
to like like hit the pause button here
for a second you're kind of like
glossing over the fact that like you
weren't just out running and riding your
bike like you were you were killing it
right you did you did Iron Man like
Placid you qualified for Boston running
like you were doing very well as an
endurance athlete you weren't just
dabbling like you were excelling yeah I
I always Excel and I I was excellent and
I thought I could have done better so I
was on a mission right to do better
um yeah so this but this particular day
was just transportation
and um you know private bus that was
hired to get Workers past restriction
zones in the city
you know made a wrong turn this this guy
made a judgment call in life that I'm
sure he's upset about
um but he he just
turned down a block that he shouldn't
have turned down he didn't see me and
next thing you know the laws of physics
as it comes through the accident
investigators didn't exist with me they
normally say that in an accident like
this I would have bounced off the bus
and the second impact is what would have
killed me
instead I got sucked under
the so the but the bus is is going up
Third Avenue it takes right on 52nd
Street and just and you're you're there
in the bike lane yep and instead of
bouncing off you go underneath the bus
and get dragged got swept under and yeah
he just kind of honked on me right and
uh all right so so you know do you have
memory of of that happening or is it all
a blur
it's it's a it's a bit of a blur
um
over time anything that that I've been
able to translate to other people has
been told to me you know I do remember
and and I have dreams about it all the
time put in my left hand up in the ABS
the bus was on my left side and like
kind of reaching up to the like slap the
side of the buses no no stop and then
that was it
um I do have very vague memories of
talking to like again it's a small City
even though there's eight billion people
here
um I knew all the firemen on the east
side so as soon as they pulled my Nomex
hood off and I heard one of the firemen
say you know oh my God it's Maddie long
from 43 truck
I closed my eyes like almost to say like
I'm in good hands now
and that's it you know then the next six
weeks I was in a medically induced coma
and
I'm not knowing anything yeah it wasn't
just that you know you were in an
accident you were about as close to
death as as somebody's going to come
absolutely I mean my doctors say one
percent but my my I'm still finally with
all my doctors and and they they when we
go out to dinner like they'd so calmly
brush over what happened to me I'm like
hey hey I'm sitting right here they're
like you were an academic exercise I'm
like what ah I'm here yeah what is that
what is that yeah because like it was
such an anomaly that you would actually
survive yeah I mean he just he just had
his residence and his interns or
whatever you call him in the medical
profession and he's had them there
saying okay what would we do for this
guy if he was going to live uh-huh if he
was going to live if and they all just I
said how do you guys do that I mean
that's like that's amazing that you can
just shut it off
and and do that I I I'm
um blessed and honored that that and and
I feel privileged that I went to the
greatest or what I think is the greatest
Hospital in the world but um
how do you you can't teach that well
it's almost a emotional defense
mechanism right if they're going to be
seeing people like every single day they
can't get emotionally invested in it
they wouldn't be able to function right
I agree I mean one of the things he told
me too later on was he goes I'm I was
more concerned about your life not your
quality of life so because you know
afterwards and I leave the hospital all
attached with different tubes and and
things I was uh he was like
I was like why would you help me so I
could live like this I'm not I'm not
living and he's like well that's not my
problem I promise to save your life my
job to save your life he goes which we
didn't think we do you're an academic
exercise we were just going through the
motions and we left the room
multiple times to come back thinking
you'd be expired
and you know your heart rate's going to
20 speeds the guy's still alive
my doctor was a marathon runner and he
uh but you know he was he's out there
doing it four and a half five hour guy
and when he went outside to tell my mom
and dad
that they're doing the best they can
we have about a one percent chance of
survival and my mom was like my mom's
stubborn Irish Catholic woman she she
just said to uh to Dr sadaka um he he
has to survive she's like he's like I'm
sorry
he's like well he just qualified for
Boston and I don't know if you run but
that's a really big deal and he's he's
got to run Boston in April and his
doctor was like we'll go back inside I
don't think you really understand what's
going on here
but then he gave me a five percent
chance so so so run down you know the
list of injuries
uh we'll go from the feed up by my left
foot leg
from a heel to hip broken compound
fractures all fractures were compound
skinned open bones out tip FIB femur
um
my right side of the pelvis was
shattered
um
my abdominal wall was torn out of my
body by the bike I was basically cut
open from stem to stern so from I
sternum to my rectum I was ripped in
half
um my right shoulder was crushed and
thank God no head trauma
you know thank God no head traveling but
but that's pretty the bulk of the life
threatening injuries was not the broken
bones it was the bite cutting me from my
sternum to my rectum severing my femoral
artery
Severin sacral nerves you know it made
the major pathway through your body mind
to muscle right just cut in half right
and and uh and so when you come out of
this coma and start to realize the
gravity of your circumstance you know
what's going through your head
huh
you know I don't think I realized it at
first because I kind of remember the
first thing I said to the doctor when I
saw him was when can I go home
meanwhile I'm holding
I'm resting my arms on a um
piece of metal that I just thought was
like a shelf connected to my bed and
then I realized it was an external
fixated holding my pelvis together and I
realized it was a part of me
um
and at that point I I was kind of like
why you know why me
and um
I don't really think that I don't want
to start a pity party for myself and I
never really did
um maybe I had my own
but um it was why did I live
you know not why this happened to me but
but okay it happened it happens to
people all the time in fact we could be
sitting here now and something could be
happening on the west side of the city
you know
but why am I still here why am I left to
go through this you know 42 surgeries
now why why then that is something that
just I played out in my head over and
over and over again like what did I do
what what why am I deserving of this
like on some karmic level yeah I you
know I just I just couldn't figure it
out and I wanted to but I couldn't
do you feel like you've answered that
question for yourself now
well I I think
yeah I I know what the answer would be
we would reaffirm yeah I I
I think that when I look back at my life
all the things I've been through
um you know
I was rolling around Life Through the
Motions you know was I successful yes in
some people's eyes I was I was a fireman
I owned two or three bars and
restaurants in Manhattan I was single so
I you know
dating wasn't a problem maybe it was a
problem maybe I did it too much I don't
know
but so yeah
I got some of your ex-girlfriends
outside oh they're gonna bring them in
yeah
I'll take curtain number one please
um so
oh but I I think that I started to
really trying to think back and like
well why what was I doing like
you know
if if it had ended what would they have
said about me what what is your what
would your legacy have been yeah and I
don't think it would have been much you
know he was a good time guy
everybody loved Maddie yeah and now post
accident
I'm fortunate enough that I had this you
know by no means do I think I did this
on my own okay I had a support group I
had tremendous family fire department
family and and was touched with written
letters or emails from around the world
how my this little fireman story you
know of don't give up spread help me not
quit and
for some reason going through the
endurance world and and you know pushing
myself for Iron Man and to get fast
enough for Boston
um
I I built strength to not quit in this
journey and now
it's it's funny as I I'll go talk and
and I'll talk to 250 people and the Q a
and no one raises their hands and then I
said it's okay I said I'm going to be in
the elevator and someone's gonna go and
going oh okay okay
I gotta tell you something and I'm like
why didn't you raise your hand
uh you know and I help them but I now
this is a very personal thing you know
it's I think he Taps into people's fears
and and you know makes them question
what their own life trajectory is all
about and that's something that most
people are not comfortable discussing in
a public forum you know but the the
short answer of that is I feel like I
have a purpose now
and it's not
going to be a world saving
purpose but it could be a life-saving
purpose for one person and if I can do
that well certainly it's already been
that yeah I would like to think it has
yes yeah yeah yes so do you look I mean
do you look back on it now like in
in addiction recovery you always hear
the guy who says like I'm a grateful
alcoholic right and when I was new in
the program I was like what does that
mean you know how could why would you be
grateful for something like that I
understand that now
um so I guess my question is do you look
back on what has happened to you with a
level of gratitude or do you still like
what is your perspective on it do you
feel like this is this has been a gift
or
or does it still is it still something
you you know it's it's a burden do you
still ask yourself why
um I don't think I ever looked at it as
as a gift but I have been asked
if
I could have that bus miss me
if I can go back in time and have that
bus miss me knowing what I know now
would I and my honest answer is no
knowing what I know now the way I've
touched people and my own life you know
never thought I'd be married I'm married
now I never thought I'd have a child I
have a child
all that wouldn't would go away if I
could have that bus miss me so
um no uh so I I would say yes it's a
gift it it it's a gift that's personal
to me in my journey
and has quite frankly
shaping the person I was supposed to be
does that color your idea of
spirituality or faith or you know
whether it's religion or some kind of
non-dogmatic version of that like you
know this idea of everything for a
reason it definitely strengthened that
100 uh I I do believe I'm a firm
believer everything happens for a reason
and I I don't believe that everyone
answers the call
um when they have an event like this or
when they have any kind of event and it
could be very small
um
and I'm sure that in my life before the
accident there were plenty times
where I've been called to step up and
hey you have a fight here or you know
you could stay in the bar and continue
to drink your beers and have a good time
be you know party time
um
so yeah it's it's uh it definitely
strengthened my my sense of faith and
and I believe in God I believe that
you know he he let me or or allowed me
to survive this accident so that I can
keep someone else from from quitting
and when does uh when does uh the idea
of starting to try to I want to get back
to like the timeline like the idea of
wanting to run again like you know
certainly you have this you know very
long protracted uh uh series of
procedures operations you know this idea
that you know you're going to be
crippled you know probably in a
wheelchair all these sorts of things
that you're having to weather like I
want to walk through that to get to the
point where the idea of actually running
a marathon starts to enter your mind
okay so uh yeah I spent five months in
the hospital
um I when I when I was hurt I was
probably about 176 177 pounds you know
really in in good shape and um
physically and aerobically I was I was
in perfect shape and that had all
dwindled Away by the time I am exiting
the hospital I'm 122 pounds
um Can can stand for maybe two to three
minutes at a time how long were you in
the hospital five months five months
yeah five months in two days to be exact
um and had I think at that point I've
gone through maybe about uh 30 33
surgeries and it was time to go home
knowing to be more surgeries uh so so
there was quite a long period of time
where
my battles became more mental you know
when in hospital you're being taken care
of you had a button anything I needed to
hit the button but now your home is when
I started to mentally realize that wow
this could be the rest of my life
um
so there was there was some very low
moments uh where I wished
that I had not lived
um what was the lowest moment
I you know we can just be open and I
guess the lowest moment is when you know
I I had a colostomy bag and and I'm in a
wheelchair and
um I'm prepping for a surgery so I don't
know I don't know why I still had to
clean my system out but
um I'm just
emptying myself all over my bathroom
because I can't physically move and boot
my and I have my number nine that's why
I call him my younger brother Eddie
number nine taking care of me you know
cleaning cleaning me cleaning up after
me and and I once that was said and done
I just
I just remember saying you know I looked
over at the counter and I had
the medication
and the volume of medication to end it
um
and I never thought well what if I
didn't have enough you know what then
what happens you know then I'm a burden
to everyone
so those thoughts came and gone quickly
quick you know I never battled with them
too much they got in my head and like
what am I you're crazy you're crazy you
know you survive now you got to get your
act together and it wasn't until a
couple months late after that that my
mom really gave me the old
tough you know hey this is it enough's
enough
got it gotta do what you got to do with
your life you got to make it the best
okay good Catholic mom you like slapping
you around wake up and and basically say
if you want to be a miserable son of a
[ __ ] do it by yourself and
and Matt hit home and then I started to
think about all the things that um
because she's not going to be
codependent in this sort of you know
yeah she wanted nothing to do with it
she wanted nothing to do with the pity
she's like look you're here you're live
we're happy you know you should be happy
and I'm blah blah blah you know you
didn't get hit by the bus but but we're
here we were there every night every day
and we're here now if you want us to be
you know much like your journey where
your parents said hey when you're ready
call us but until then right you're out
so it was pretty much the same thing um
and and and then the attitude changed
that at that point the attitude changed
I I stopped thinking about the things
that were taken from me I stopped
thinking about the words I can't uh and
now I joke about it when I talk I said
if you wake up every morning and say you
can't go back to bed I said don't go to
work because you're useless just call
the boss I'm taking an I can't think
[Music]
um
and the attitude became I will and
just let's say two to three months of of
really not going through the motions of
therapy anymore really pay attention to
the therapist really pushing myself and
and when they were happy I stood and
walked six steps I was happy I walked
six steps and I said okay now what would
I do before my action well let's walk
seven steps unless it walks eight and
now let's do those eight steps faster
and and on and on and on and then
eventually I said to myself
um
enough's enough I have to close this
page of my life and move on and the only
way I'm going to do it is if I'm able to
run again I don't want the bus
to take
something I loved away from me you know
I'll leave it on my own terms when you
talk about the physical therapy uh and
Rehab what about the mental and
emotional like where you know the the
the psychologists the psychiatrists the
shrinks the emotional aspect of trying
to repair yourself
um I
I went I went a couple times to a
psychiatrist and um I don't think he was
the right match for me yeah it sounds
like that was a misfire yeah it was it
was a big misfire and
um I just you know I'm kind of that guy
I'm you know maybe
get blindsided in a conversation and you
miss all the facts around it and all I
heard was
you know I have my tennis elbow keeps me
from playing tennis and I was like does
this freaking guy just tell me your
tennis elbow
and that's always in my head and and I
was like I'm out of here you know you
get the wrong guy and then I learned
that you know sometimes
the best therapy is right in front of
you and and here I am being driven to
therapy by a fireman a friend of mine
who has a rare blood disease
you know after being down at 9 11 for
months and months
and
his fate is unknown
Maybe uncurable
and
you know I'm feeling bad for myself
because I'm gonna may live in a
wheelchair so me and him started to talk
and that became my therapy you know I
kept sitting here looking at him saying
you know how do you get up every day
come and take care of me when you don't
know what lies ahead for you right so um
so that's powerful man I mean that's
that's a lot like you know I mean that's
basically the foundation of addiction
recovery one addict or alcoholic talking
to another
yeah being able to share that that
common experience
yeah we strengthen that we and we did we
shared a lot of stories and a lot about
fears and
and he helped me through a lot of things
I mean I think he might have been one of
the first firemen that I was able to cry
in front of you know
um
and and and that that helped that helped
and that that pushed me and I set it I
haven't been to a psychiatrist since
um
but no I'm not saying that I don't
suffer from any post-traumatic stress or
anything I just deal with it differently
right
um you know and I I'm lucky enough that
I could still deal with it on a bike and
you know yeah so so how you know how did
Iron Man
Marathon running that experience of
training pushing your body you know
understanding your physical limitations
and all of that how did that play into
um
the physical recovery going from six
steps to seven steps and and being able
to maintain focus and positivity well at
first it wasn't
um any help at all because I couldn't
let go
of the athlete I was or the athletes
it's actually getting in the way it was
getting in the way because as my
therapist
um you know one of the things we we
started to do and I had when when the
wheels started turning and I said I was
talking to your wife earlier about it
and I said you know uh I started
research on everything I'm doing
everything I can to get better so when
some people say oh did you try
acupuncture I'm like I did did it work I
don't know and I'm like why don't you
know I said because
yeah I did everything together so I'm
going to say yes it worked you know for
me
so I remember when my my one therapist I
had um hired my therapist to come home
and one day a week from the hospital
when I was home I was doing therapy
three days in the hospital gym three
days and then two days a week the
therapist came to me
and we would just go out and walk
and you know went from two crutches we'd
walk around the block and I go timing
and next week she come back what was
that time you write that well and I kept
my journal so when she'd get happy that
I walked around a city block in 13
minutes
I started to say well you know I'm two
miles in already
um
yeah the old match two miles in 13
minutes
you know this is nonsense don't get
happy for me this is not a good time but
it's about changing your perspective
it's not about like oh I'm qualifying
for Boston or you know how am I going to
get to Kona as an Iron Man athlete it's
how am I going to go around the block
you know 30 seconds faster than I did
last week right and that's when things
started to tick and change and and
that's when I had to say
for now I had to say goodbye to the
memory of the athlete that was before
the bus and say
forget about his results but don't
forget about the work he put in to
become that athlete so let's put that
work in here and get faster and let's
put that working fast and get rid of one
crutch and and get on your own feet so
how did you flick that switch like was
there something happen or was that a
gradual kind of realization that was the
attitude you were going to have to adopt
it was very gradual but
um I do it definitely came from the two
therapists that the two girls that uh
that that helped me you know they they'd
come in they'd eventually tell me they
look you know you know this is
emotionally draining for us you're
making us cry every time we leave here
and I'm like why and I like because
you're so hard to accept the progress
you don't see it you know you shouldn't
be alive
and you're walking around the block
except that and I was like wow I said
you know what you're right find the
Gratitude yeah I said you're right I'm
sorry and I didn't know that was making
you cry and and I said you're right and
let's let's let's let's set some goals
now let's set some things let's put some
things in order and you know I said to
myself once I was walking without uh or
at least down to a cane that's when I
started to look for other places to go
and leave the city for a little while
and and that's what I said to myself you
know what I will run again yeah and
that's it and they're like all right you
know
so I did it yeah I went out to Arizona
uh trained uh my I treated myself like
an athlete um
I rented a small apartment near the
Arizona
near the um Arizona State found a place
that would accept me for therapy and
I've just done an email sent them my
story sent them newspaper links and I
said I want to run again and these two
young one therapist and one strength
coach emailed me back saying we'd never
tell anyone they couldn't run and I flew
out there that was it that was it just
that one little like that little Ray of
Hope yep the other places I had emailed
some of them wrote back
um set realistic goals you know you've
been through a lot and I was just like
delete delete I wanted to email him back
and it just would have gone nowhere yeah
um so when I saw this email I said uh I
called them up I said where's a good
place to live there and they said well
why don't you go down by Arizona State
and that's okay
so I flew out there with a friend and um
he flew home the next day we got an
apartment A guy got a car with handicap
controls I started driving again I
haven't driven a car in two and a half
years
[Music]
um
and that was it I told them my goal I'm
here for three months and so my goals
get strong enough to run and the day
with the day I left I ran my first mile
wow 22 minutes wow so what was it that
they had to kind of put back together
like what were the mechanics of trying
to get you from somebody who was on
crutches to somebody who could actually
run
with him with them I went back to basic
um strength building and
um three days a week was therapy there
was a massage therapy involved
um
more
um the functional movements that that
you would get in the hospital let's work
on your rotator cuff let's work on your
hip let's work on your hamstring and
then the two days a week with the
strength coach was his method of
basically you look your body doesn't
just move up and down it moves in
multiple directions so let's start
teaching those muscles they have to
operate in multiple directions and we
started you know he calls it Triplex
training right and um
and I was doing very simple stuff in a
stretch cage just lunging to the right
lunging to the left turning and twisting
and it eventually started to work
started firing up the muscles in his
theory and and I agree now
wholeheartedly the body wants to be
healthy and when one part of the body
can't do its job
the muscles around it say all right how
can we pitch in so um to this day my I
don't have a glute so like I'm looking
at you and I'm sitting I'm sitting on my
my left butt cheek right just to keep me
level if I go like that you know I'm
down I have no muscle on the right side
for my right glute so all the muscles
around it pitch in and help me right so
that's what we started to do and and
what kind of range of motion do you I
mean you have a you have a titanium rod
running down the left leg
and a nine inch titanium screw going
through my pelvis on from the right side
um but
um my range of motion is pretty good in
fact it may be more so on my right side
because my pelvis was reset almost a
half inch to an inch higher so um
the there's a lot of movement on my
right side right that I can't control uh
if I do stretch and stuff like that I do
it with a band or a rope that I learned
at the Wharton performance center here
in the city because they took me to the
next level
um and and I control it because once I
get to a certain point it could be like
whoa yeah
I'm sorry but when you do so all right
so when you you finally accomplish that
goal and you run that one mile I mean
this is a watershed moment I mean this
isn't just it's not just hey I wanna I
wanna run again because I love running I
mean this is a symbolic you know
accomplishment that I think means much
more than just you know I've repaired
myself enough that I can move my body
better than I could three months prior
yeah um it was I was frightened to be
honest with you I was frightened I said
to them well
you know we had no attempt at running
before this no attempt and I said well I
guess I'll fall three times if I fall
three times we stop and walk back and go
back to work
um but I ran the whole way without
falling and
at the very moment of my last step
I looked at my watch and said you know
we still got 20 minutes left on a
therapy session let's go inside and go
to work because I want to run the
marathon and they were like excuse me
I said I said yeah I said this was a
part
of the steps I wanted to take I said I
need
to cross that finish line I said I don't
care how long it takes me but I need to
finish my marathon and the reaction
and they were pretty cool about it right
there they both actually said uh they
both act mock the therapist was like you
run the marathon I'll be there
I said okay and I said Kyle he goes I'll
try that's okay so
um
left Arizona in April but hold on a
second so is that is that floating
around in your head like all right I'm
going to get through this one mile I'm
going to make this announcement I mean
obviously you're thinking about this but
are you thinking like if I can do this
one mile then I'm going to like say that
the marathon is my goal or was that a
spontaneous sort of thing that came
complete spontaneous uh you know I had
always thought about it like will I have
a run again Bubba you know finish the
marathon but the way it came out was
complete spot like an ideolation of of
getting through that one mile get into
it one mile and then knowing to myself
knowing who I was as a person before I'm
very goal driven I need something to
look forward to otherwise I'll fall in
through the motions again in life so as
soon as I completed that and they their
question was well what do you want to do
now I said that's it I want to run the
marathon I said well we got 25 minutes
left so let's go back to work and we
started strength building again and and
the next day I got on my plane and and
uh and we came home yeah and then that's
when I started researching in Iowa who
takes me me to the next step in New York
and who was that
it all all fingers pointed to Jim and
Phil Wharton of the Wharton performance
center they got a place in Arizona and
they got a place here
um and then he what he did was he took
me from what I did in Arizona which was
more uh one-dimensional therapeutic he
took me to more
um I'm sorry over there was I was on all
different planes and and and
three-dimensional exercises and he took
me to Let's concentrate on your
weaknesses let's let's get the muscles
let's give the muscles that have been
helping you a break and let's work on
the hamstring that doesn't work let's
work on the glute that doesn't work
let's fire these up let's start thinking
about what you're doing and I when I
went in for a evaluation
he gave a piece of paper he wrote down
he goes I write down your medical
problems and issues and I wrote
first of all there's like two lines so I
just wrote [ __ ]
and put an explanation point this this
Jim came in he's like [ __ ] this guy's
[ __ ] and I said yeah I'm sorry Jim I
just there's nothing else I just don't
want to write any more about what's
wrong I told him I was sorry he goes
damn
let's tell a new story yep you know I
like that I mean tell me about the pain
like you know there's the the challenge
of trying to run this one mile but like
what is what are you experiencing
physically when you're trying to do that
at this point I'm still taking some some
pain meds yeah I was going to say what
kind of meds are you on what does that
look like yeah I was still on a low dose
of oxy and a slow release like percocet
um
that I learned
um pretty much by myself when and when
not to take it so that I would get
through the training session or get
through the night you know
um of sleep that you need because you
know at to this day I talked to everyone
everyone I train or people I train with
I'm like you know what you're doing now
is great but if you don't rest tomorrow
you're not building yourself you're not
making yourself any Stronger Yeah you
just they think they're going to get it
now if they keep yeah so um
uh
I was able to deal with the pain on a
day-to-day basis going through
the training regimen and the therapy
it was the pain that
I suffered after attempts of running and
um you know going because you know look
now I'm now at this point now I'm doing
pain management but now I'm trying to
get onto a marathon plan you know in
five months
and you know
um
it's it's a lot harder to run slow
than it is to get it over with in three
hours and you're out there for so much
longer and I'm gonna be out there for
double yeah the amount of time you know
and I was out there for seven and a half
hours
um so so the the day after my runs my
recovery days were brutal were really
brutal and it all stemmed from my my
lower back or that right side glute uh
stabilizer muscle area that were gone
and non-existent
after a couple a couple 90 miles after a
half mile which would take me you know
eight to ten minutes
the the swag swagger I had when I run
just crushed my back yeah yeah you have
so you're you're exposing yourself to
injuring yourself on all kinds of other
crazy ways
trying to do that right so but it's also
this transition of going from
rehabilitative to being kind of
proactively athletic right it's taking
you out of the context of we're
rehabilitating you after this accident
to okay you're an athlete and we're
preparing you for an event
like that's a mental shift as well as a
sort of a physical uh and kind of
program you know kind of alteration the
way that you're perceiving how you're
approaching your day-to-day you know
physical routine absolutely and and
going back to a question we talked about
before now this is where
I am in marathon training before the
accident starts to help me right so now
you're starting to think like are you
starting to feel like yeah you can tap
into this I know this like this feels
familiar like I'm back in that lane
right I'm not you know I'm not worried
about the time I'm producing in my
efforts right now but I know that I Can
Go the Distance I know that you know
I've been on those hundred mile bike
rides by myself
to train myself and I am in when the
your head starts telling you what are
you doing out here you know maybe you
should just pull over and stop you know
you fight those demons so I said I've
beaten those demons before I can push
myself
to the point where others would sit down
and take that break so I just need to
know that I I got to do it and it's
going to take a lot longer now and what
are your buddies telling you now and
like what's your family saying I mean
are they are they being supportive
yeah most of the people were 100
supportive to me now whether they when I
left the room said you know what's he
thinking
um or we're worried about what's going
to happen if he doesn't just doesn't
work out right I I so I didn't know too
much of that
um I had my two friends Frank Carino and
Noel Flynn
both uh sub three hour marathon runners
um they were with me pretty much doing
my training and they were going to run
the race with me that day
um it was like two nights before the
marathon my brother Jim who was also a
fireman he calls me up
and at this point in training I got to
14 miles and it took me about four hours
so Jim Wharton says and I shut down like
I I had to be actually thank God for
cell phones and some of the modern
changes in life I had to call my buddy
and say look I'm sitting on the side of
the road in the park I can't move um and
my hip locked up my back was seized I I
they literally came got me put me in a
cab picked me up in a firehouse and put
me in a a garbage pail full of ice
and um so I told Jim I said Jim Wharton
I said I I couldn't get past 14 miles I
we have two months or months five weeks
I said I don't know what are we going to
do
and he just said um
yeah we're gonna we're gonna adapt we're
gonna adapt we know we can get it done
we know we can finish we know you can
keep going he goes now we just gotta
take care of the body get you to healthy
so we dialed it down and it was more of
a mental thing than it was a physical
thing now for me to complete that
Marathon but uh so two nights before the
after that event my brother called me up
and says
you know the newspapers the local
newspapers are making a story about this
fireman making an incredible comeback
less than three years from near fatal
accident
he said to me um
what are you going to say to them if you
fail
and I said excuse me excuse me what
what'd you just say he said well Jim he
goes Matt
if you don't finish
they're going to want to know why
you're a story no matter what now and
what if you don't finish
and I said um did you wake up this
morning so you're gonna kick me in the
balls because that's what you just did
like well you know how is that helpful
yeah I'm like you know he we kind of had
the chuckle like we just did and and he
said nah I'm just trying to be honest
with you and and I said okay you know I
appreciate it I said it took me a little
bit of time and I said you know what I'm
going to town
I said
three years ago I was supposed to die
if I finished 20 miles tomorrow
and leave 6.2 on the course it's not 6.2
miles of failure but 20 miles of success
behind me and that's the way I'm going
to look at it how about just showing up
at the at the start line you know what I
mean some would think that was a success
it goes back to this idea that I know
you feel strongly about which is it's
the journey man it's the journey like
you had the balls to stand up the spine
to say I'm going to tackle this and take
this on and yeah I might fail I don't
know but I'm gonna show up for it and
you know five weeks earlier I seized up
at 14 miles and here I am I'm still
going to do this and whether or not you
succeed or fail I think is irrelevant
and you can't control how you know the
the narrative that the media is going to
adapt around that but I would imagine
you know they're going to still
celebrate the fact that you even tried
and I think you know what we haven't
really talked about is that you were you
took this on very much in the spotlight
because it you know in the wake of your
accident this was a big story right so
people were paying attention people knew
who you were they're watching you right
and so the pressure that came along with
that whether you cave and decide you
know I can't take this on or you decide
to rise to the occasion that's a story
regardless yeah you're right and it's
funny that you say it because uh well
part of the reasons for me leaving New
York to go to Arizona was to try to get
away from me and and the what was the
icing on the cake one night and I I
would my daily routine became okay get
get the crutches on get get taken care
of it cleaned up and now I'm going to
um take the one block journey to
Starbucks to get my coffee in the
morning and walk back to my apartment
that was part of me getting out into the
fresh air and the homeless guy outside
Starbucks sees me walking in and he goes
my man
you're the guy that get hit by the bus
and I was like oh
yeah oh man I've been praying for you
when I'm like well I'm praying for you
too thank you very much and I went
inside I'm like even the homeless guy
knows who I am so I need to get away
that's so funny all right so so all
right so you get that phone call you
have that 14 mile you know experience I
mean did you was that still your longest
run lead that's up into the marathon so
you didn't try to go out there and Trump
that before a race day nope I didn't try
again I kept um I kept any outdoor
running
um to
between three and five miles and we were
down to three days a week at that and
then everything else was done either
just to build some aerobic power and I
was swimming
um I was doing indoor cycling
um and I was on the elliptical so I
would to mix it up I would do maybe all
three for an hour or there were times
when I was on an elliptical for three
hours right but just not as much
pounding right even pounding and and the
recovery time has to be far greater I
mean what else you're doing I would
imagine you're doing ice bass you know
the rest aspect of what you were doing
had to really require a bunch of focus
yeah 100 and I was doing ice baths I was
doing acupuncture this time I was doing
everything to try to regenerate nerves
um you know I was taking every recovery
supplement that you know you read about
right someone's doing this okay I'll do
that you know no no put your left hand
in the air when you do that oh my God
any any anything if this worked for me I
was trying it all I was really trying it
all so um
you know
more importantly you know I was mentally
focused and and you're right you're 100
right it looking back it is about the
journey more than it is about
the Finish
um
but my journey wasn't over until I for
me until I crossed that Finish Line you
know mentally it it it it kind of gave
me this um
gave me this victory over
so maybe it wasn't really about crossing
the finish line of the marathon but but
give me the victory over the bus to say
well you didn't take running from me
you know I'm not fast anymore I don't
even look good while I'm running
but you didn't take it away from me you
know I got I still have that if I want
it yeah it doesn't have
that power over you right and you know I
obviously went further from that day but
at some point it turned around and said
well
these are the things I love these are
the things that that strengthened me
these are things that gave me enjoyment
and I still have them but now I'm
leaving them on my terms not because you
hate me right right right and when you
show up on race day are you thinking I'm
finishing this thing or are you thinking
I don't know man but I'm here I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna give it a try like
what's the mental state
you know Marathon Sunday
you know they gave me a three hour head
start with the Achilles track athletes
and um
I was grateful because I was like oh you
know the firemen are all going to be
done everyone's gonna be done out
partying already like I said party
everything in your party Marathon so um
I so I had appealed to the Achilles
track club and and they were grateful
enough to to let me start with them and
it was about 30 of us hand Cycles
wheelchair amputees
blind Runners it was amazing and
from the naked eye to nothing really
looked until I started to move
[Music]
you wouldn't think anything was wrong
with me uh Mary Wittenberg the the head
of uh New York Road Runners
um
she gave me a big shout out as she
started that little group of of Achilles
athletes and I used to tell my friends
you know are they like oh challenged
athletes I'm like whoa I'm not a
challenged athlete I said I'm an athlete
with challenges there's a big difference
so that's the way I kind of looked at it
and
um I didn't know if I'd finish
okay but multiple little things happened
along people I saw uh in fact so since I
had a three-hour Head Start the Fire in
the morning even at
the starting line yet oh wow they were
still at the hotel in the city loading
their buses and as I'm going over to
Arizona Bridge
line of buses stopped and they're out
the windows yelling my name yeah waving
their flags and I was just like wow like
go Maddie they all passed me a mile 16.
so that was a kick in the bowls right
there yeah but you got to be that guy
he's like you know here come the elite
women yeah
yeah that was my first up close and
personal uh view of Carrick Goucher
right so I was like Paula Radcliffe
she's pretty cute
um
yeah wow so so uh you know walk me
through that experience I mean you know
there's nothing like the New York
Marathon I mean just the the incredible
uh you know environment the supportive
you know crowds the entire way I mean
there's just there's there's no other
race like it and for you to be this
HomeTown Story you know that everybody
is kind of you know they're up to speed
on everybody knows what's going on with
you I mean it had to be
You know despite the incredible
challenges and struggles of trying to
get through those 26 miles to kind of
absorb that support along the way had to
carry you quite a bit it it absolutely
did and luckily enough that that I've
involved myself in New York city so much
through firemen through growing up in
Brooklyn
um that almost like we didn't even talk
about you being like at Ground Zero and
9 11 the experience of 9 11 and all of
that I mean it's just you're you're
you're part of the fabric of this city
yeah all right so right that's that's a
good way to look at it it's true and and
fortunate for me that that 26 Point mile
Journey at every point
there was someone there that at this
point where the same reason why I left
New York City is why what I needed to
finish this Marathon I needed someone to
say there's Matt right yo there's the
guy and um I'm sure you got a lot of
that I got a lot I got a lot of it for
the first
nine miles because it was just us it was
just me Noel Frank and Charlie Butler
the guy who who co-wrote my book with me
um
and so we got a lot of that in the early
morning and then when the running
started come by me
you know especially I started with 30
channel uh Achilles Track Club athletes
and I finished in 40 000th place
so 39
970 people passed me and a good chunking
and patted me on the back uh as they
went by or gave me words of
encouragement so they pushed me through
a lot of the early miles and then you
hit mile uh 15 14 to 16 you're on First
Avenue well that's where I just lived
for five months in the hospital my
therapist they were out you know on the
Avenue cheering me on uh at the Finish
Line my doctors and his family were
there and one of the one of the best
moments of my finish and you know I was
emotional I cried and my family was
there but one of the best moments is
when my trauma surgeon Dean large
has I think he's three girls now and his
baby was born
just a month or two after I was hurt and
he had to leave his home during
Christmas he had to leave he had to get
his wife out of bed rest and to get only
to get to the hospital just to help be a
part of Saving my life and he looked at
his daughter and said his older
daughters and said
this is why daddy's not home hmm
um you know I I looked at them and I
said Thank you thank you for
understanding that you know because
that's tough he he's a trauma surgeon he
just he's not a guy you make an
appointment with and uh that was one of
my best moments uh with him at least I'm
still friends with him and and I'm very
grateful that they
that they sacrificed their lives and had
their calling to be the best that they
could be extraordinary yeah I mean it's
easy to kind of go oh you know Matt and
his you know amazingly inspirational
story and look look what he did and
that that belies the fact that there is
this extraordinary team of people you
know behind every success whether
athletic professional or otherwise like
you don't get there alone and
you know it's cool to hear you recognize
all the people that help you on your
journey
I you definitely don't get there alone
you don't you know I whether you meet
them when you're falling down that
ladder again uh you know to
I don't know but um but you don't
you don't achieve
true success by yourself and whether
that's happiness or financial success
whatever you don't you know and that
person I'd be wary of the person who
says I did this by myself I'm self-made
and screw you because that's what he
would do what he would do
yeah self-made is a an illusion yeah I
think uh so so what was the feeling when
you crossed the finish line
you know at first I I remember the
finish line and there's some controversy
around my finish
um it was a probably bad judgment call
but
um I don't know if you ever seen the
videos which but there was an incident
right before the Finish now let's put
let's put Let me um not defend my
actions but let me I'll tell you them
because it's part of what I did so you
have to own up to it uh I'm out there
for seven hours and 18 minutes at Mile
26
5.8 I stopped mm-hmm
and didn't say it didn't say a word I
was in pain
um
I wanted to quit and I only had you know
four tenths of a mile ago I wanted to
quit I really did and the guys now at
this point I was only running with three
other people
but at this point a so-called Entourage
has come around me other people have
given up their day to run with me and
now the pat grew to maybe 17 people
and
um
you know I I would say that my vision
was blurred I would say that you know I
was not thinking straight and
we turn get into the park I start
running again
and there's a there's a gentleman
jumping up and down at the finish line
and not in any hurry to finish
in fact he had a video camera and he was
just kind of videoing the crowd
apploring at the line
[Music]
and I just kept saying to myself that
you know I had a path and he's there
and I'm not going to fall down at the
Finish like this is you know where I'm
going so I kind of Heisman trophied
this Runner and
[Music]
went on my way and of course the Finish
Line dropped down the floor do 10
push-ups was I wanted to do push-ups
before I started balling crying which
didn't help because I got up and balled
and cried anyway
um but it was a big controversy about
the push and why did I push him you go
back to the videotape he was he wasn't
in your way
do I regret pushing him yes do I own up
to in fact that I pushed him yes mm-hmm
yeah were you Delirious were you you
know I could come up with a thousand
excuses instead I just decided to say in
the internet world of slow twitch and
and the people that were killing me for
it and calling me a bad person I just
came out and basically said you know
what you're right you know I shouldn't
have done it and
if I could apologize to this rhino I
would yeah I mean speaking from somebody
who has some experience with being
Delirious in the midst of an endurance
challenge you know it brings out a
certain aspect of who you are that might
not always be so pretty I mean I had you
know similar experience when I did epic
five and I was beyond tired and could
barely you know function and that's what
I always say like in these Ultra
endurance races don't don't bring your
friends as your crew members they won't
be your friends anymore no there's dark
there's dark moments you know where then
you come out of it and you're like I
can't believe I behave like that so
you know this I I you know I think that
that for anybody who hasn't sort of
walked a mile in the shoes of what that
is like that they should Reserve
judgment on that but you know I haven't
seen the video but thanks for being
honest and open about that
um but you you know so you have this
extreme you know extraordinary
experience of finishing this Marathon
then it then it's this big story then
Runner's World writes this you know
remarkable article about it I mean and
that's I I my understanding is that's
what kind of paved the way for you to
write the book and everything that's
come from that I mean is that how that
came about absolutely one you know 100
the um the
and in fact we were working on the
article before I even dreamed of running
the marathon again
um the 2000 and so I was 2005 that I my
last marathon got hurt 2005. so the
2006 Marathon
um Charlie Butler was working for
Verona's world and he was doing a story
of The Gangs of New York the different
the different running teams in New York
and two other teams were the police and
the firemen
so they had made shirts this year they
had shirts that said go long on the back
and it was for me and they didn't make
it stink about it they just did it I
didn't know about it until race day and
Charlie was asking him for what's this
go long and one of my friends Tom
Grimshaw who's a little bit older than
me but was a big influence of my running
told him the story
he was like wow I'd like to get in touch
with him you know another story
and Charlie and I had met a couple times
and and I was still not in a really good
place so the meetings we had were he was
still intrigued but I was kind of like
whatever and
um
then I disappeared on them for about six
months and I went to Arizona and they
did my thing and and I came home and I
emailed them and said Charlie it's Matt
long and I have been around but um still
interested and he's like well I'm not
sure you know what are you doing I go
the marathon he's like hello email
stopped the phone call then and we sat
down and did the story and it wound up
being the largest article runs world
ever published on a single athlete it
was like 14 pages and then we'd guess
and run his world and Charlie and I
turned it into into the long run of the
book and the book you know had
an extraordinary life it was an
incredible success and I'm sure you know
opened up tons of doors for you I mean
how you know how is your life
I mean how I would say how has it
changed but like how has it not changed
you know I mean everything about your
life is different yeah I I've lived a
good life I really have
um but but you know
being able to to spread
any bit of inspiration is is truly a
gift that uh
that I'm happy to have so the book
getting my story out a little further
don't you know don't get me wrong
there's some places I go and it's you
know this is great because it's gonna
put the kids through school it is gonna
you know pay some bills
but but the bottom line is um you know
when I get out there and I'm able to
help one person
um and I always get an email it doesn't
matter you know you get the email you
gotta just stopped in the elevator
wherever and they tell you their story
and then they realize that that you know
they're not the only ones out there
having a tough time mm-hmm
one of the things that I always uh
talk about is the incredible resiliency
of resilience resiliency resilience uh
the work the human body the human Spirit
you're certainly an example of that I
mean how do you kind of you know when
you were talking about like I'm trying
to regenerate these nerve endings and
you know that's on the like micro level
of like repairing the body but but it
goes all the way to
you know the highest level of repairing
your spirit your perspective of the
world You Know Your Role what is your
legacy what is your what is your gift
and what are you leaving behind and and
there's nothing more powerful than a
story a story well told an incredible
story well told you're certainly you're
certainly that I mean how do you you
know kind of look at look at this path
um
and translate that into something that
somebody can extract something to help
them right that's not very well said but
you know what I'm saying like like how
you know like like how do you take your
story and say all right uh you know how
can I convey
my experience in a way that somebody can
take something from that and implement
it into their life for the better you
know you know I I think it's I think it
could be simply answered with two words
or replacing words and it's basically
starting your day with I will
whatever
that means for you whatever is at task
for the day the week the month whatever
your goals are you know we the body
intrinsically wants to be healthy so
you don't have a bad back now look there
are people with back problems and things
with real issues
but a lot of people have a bad back
because
they're sanitary they just sit around
and they're they're not active the body
wants to move the body wants to get up
so that bad could be telling 85 percent
of the people in this world get up you
know lose 10 pounds strengthen your core
and the back will stop burn I had a bad
back I went to chiropractors
I started running I got in shape I the
back pain went away the body wants to be
healthy
so
what I talk to people about is look I'm
not telling you go into an Iron Man I'm
not telling you got into a marathon you
know find what it is for you that's
going to make you happy and do it
I use the analogy of the the stove you
know which has come a long way but when
I was growing up or when I worked in
Harlem it was always just an old school
stove with a pilot light in the middle
and you know that light went out you had
a gas leak
I said
the human spirit
is what will drive you to to heal your
body and that human spirit is the pilot
light
someone's got to turn the knob on and
for me it was my mom who said you know
let's get those burners going
and once I did that
you know am I perfectly healed now no I
walk with a limp I my stabilizer I can't
stand on my right leg I can't move my
right arm higher than uh you know 95
percent
but but I'm Healed mentally
because of my human Spirit yeah that is
there's nothing wrong with it there's no
metal in my spirit there's no it's just
there and it flows because
you know I I love my family
extended and my own and and I I try now
to stay as healthy as I can so that when
I'm older I know it's ahead of me I know
it's the arthritis is coming and what I
know it's going to be ahead of me when
I'm older but I'm going to be as healthy
and a strong
mentally so that I can handle it and
that's what I try to tell people I'm
like you know you have it you mean
you're exactly the same we have the same
pilot light right just gotta right right
so but if somebody's out there who's
listening and they feel stuck they're
struggling uh you know they're out of
shape or they just don't know what the
first thing to do is like they don't
know you know how to turn that pilot
light on or they don't know who that
person is in their life that they can
turn to or rely on like how do you you
know what is the message the message
would be to do
an inventory check on your life
and it may be one of the hottest
decisions you have to make when you do
that inventory check because you'll find
out
who it is or what it is
that's keeping you back
and you know it could be the person
that's closest to you we have to say you
know what I just can't deal anymore I
can't do it anymore I can't be around
the negativity
that's going to keep me in this hole you
know and and you know I said that like I
lost friendships post accident
um
you know there were guys that just were
happy enough that I lived and said deal
with it you know it is it you're okay
you know we'll go out with you in a
wheelchair and I'm like well that's not
what I want and
that attitude
that energy you know and I'm not you
know this big you know atmospheric uh
you know it's in the Stars type of guy
but that energy is not helping me
you know I don't need the person to tell
me
just be happy with being alive I said
well what's good is being alive of not
living and to me the living was running
living was being active living was
staying in shape so you know he here I
would tell this person you have to do an
inventory check find out go back to
being a kid what was going on in your
life when you were happy
and I tell people all the time I realize
it I did those inventory checks more
than once because we again we didn't
talk about 911 but after 9 11 I battled
a little depression and I started to do
an inventory check
what was I doing
in the times of my life when I was
happiest
and it came down to one thing
I was dreaming
simple as a kid you dream as adult we
set goals it's the same freaking thing
so for me that is what I found and I
started to dream again about running
about Cyclone about having a family and
and I have it Amen brother I love that
thank you you know you said earlier that
that that goals are really important to
you to help keep you structured and
focused and whether it's Dreaming or
goal setting so you know what's the goal
now what do you dream about now or
what's next well you know athletically
is how it goes for me you know so I'm 49
well I'll be 49 this year and is there
something there's something you probably
don't know so after my bus accident like
what else can happen to me right I was
like wow the guy hit by a bus and he
lives and like you know how much his bad
luck cards are over you know
so um I show up at a bike race in
Central Park and um i line up with the
cat fives and some guys looks at me and
says hey aren't you the guy hit by the
bus I'm like hey because what are you
doing here
so I'm gonna try to race with you guys
he's like really so
boom gun goes off and we we start our
first like 70 guys and we started our
first lap around Central Park and the
first climb that my right glute is is
evident I'm done I'm drunk can't get
back in the field
I roll around my five six laps and at
the end of the race I see that guy again
he goes how'd it go I thought it was
dropped dropped in the first lap he goes
you know
you should be trying out with the power
athletes and I never looked at myself
like that so I said what you know I took
it into it I went home I started
Googling it and researching it I'm like
you know I email the guy from the para
cycling committee and he's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah without a doubt I sent
him my information so I go now my goal
back this was in 2000 um
2010 2000 2010 right after I finished
the Iron Man
um
is to become a Power cyclist and go to
the Olympics
so I go down to Augusta Georgia for the
parent National cyclist Cyclone Champion
world champions
again I did it without asking questions
so I didn't know what was really going
on I went down there I had my road bike
I signed up for the long cost Road Race
as a C3 uh classified
paracycles
all the C1 through C5 race together so
we're in a pack of 50 60 people men and
women
oh no the women actually started behind
behind us because I got passed by quite
a few of them
um so amputees you know they're all
there in the pack and you go and you
finish so I've really never had an idea
of what was going to happen at the end
of this 28 mile race but I finished
across the line and I got called up for
a gold medal so I'm a Paran national
champion and I'm like looking around and
they're not calling anyone else so I go
up to the podium and I'm like um
who would I be like I was like are you
the only one in the race you're like
you're in your category like what
so I was like so it goes in line with
the men's fitness thing
I'll take it but don't make me stand on
the podium go over the uh go where the
herd is thin right you know um so it
turns out that in the the American uh
paranational racing is so far behind
European
that they really only concentrate on
time trial and track here because you're
so far ahead of us so when they go to
the Olympics they they want to send so
all the C3 guys were in the hotel
sleeping for the time trial the next day
and I didn't compete in that I gotcha so
uh anyway so Mike where are you taking
this so I'm I'm now I'm talking to the
coach I'm like well you know can I do
this can I try this he's like absolutely
you need to get officially certified in
your injury I said no problem and he
gave me like you know some coaching tips
and I said well I'm going to start the
train for the 2012 London Olympics
he's like awesome
so I go to my 2011 year start in Florida
to do 10-day you know summer trip first
day I get hit by a Buick no way broke my
arm slid across the road ah I didn't
know that oh my God so that I remember
completely that hurt as I didn't lose
Consciousness I thought you were
pre-disaster you know like that's not
supposed to happen again you know I was
like oh my God me and my buddy were
cruising down and again my friend Noel
Flynn who ran with me he was he came
down on the Cyclone trip he was into
cyclone and Triathlon so um
I'm right on his wheel and I'm like this
is great we're feeling awesome I'm like
yeah it's good what's it saying oh my
God 25 25 miles an hour let's go let's
go we had a mile to go 49 the 49th mile
we had a mile to go home
and uh car turns right in front of us I
hear him yell [ __ ] I'm like ah he goes
up and over I slid under Landing to the
side he slid under the car no like hit
the side of it like slid the floor into
the
broke my arm you know Road Rash the the
if we have time the long the funny story
about it is it happened in front of a
bar in in Clearwater Beach called
um Crabby Bills
the bar empties out because we got there
for the first day so it was like four
o'clock it was a late day riding
the bar empties out and there's a whole
bunch of guys so the fire trucks they're
they're putting me in the Stokes basket
they're stabilizing my neck and my
friend and so I tell uh the fireman I go
listen if
guys I'm a New York City firefighter and
thank God I had my fire department kid
on so they're like oh okay so just don't
take me to a bad Hospital you know that
I don't expect just get me to a good
Hospital New York City fire minutes
please just take me where you would go
and they're like all right don't worry
about it we'll we'll take care of you
and um I now I'm wrapped up so I can
only see straight and I hear the the
paramedic goes to someone on the side of
the road so yeah you're a fireman the
guy's like yeah yeah I'm a fireman he's
like so is the guy in the street oh yeah
what's his name see what's your name so
I say my name all you hear is guy go
again
I don't know I'm trying to look like who
is that
so I'm in the emergency room in Florida
and the nurse comes in and says Mr long
and I go yeah yeah that's me okay you
got a visit I go the only guy that knows
him here is in the bed next to me
and through three drunk firemen came in
to visit me oh wow so the fraternity
though man wherever you go right yeah
wherever you go that's amazing that
ended my uh Quest so that is your quest
so so where does that leave you now
though are you like back on the bike or
I'm back at it I'm back um I'm back
racing my racing my bike
um more a little more focused uh because
I'm still racing as a cat five and still
having problems staying with them so but
this year I uh I really focused um
started a a program with a cycling team
in Brooklyn
um and I'm I'm making every you know
it's not when you're in your 40s and
you're training for something you it's
not like you could you have tomorrow
like ah it's getting done tomorrow it's
like wait a minute you know every
second's got to count here I got a
two-year-old yeah you know so
everything's got to count so I'm really
I think for the first time in my life as
an athlete I'm training with a purpose
you know with every workout has a reason
uh every work that has a certain time
that has to get done and everything's
going pretty smooth so far so so yeah
I'm so I'm just I want to race my wife
knows I want to race she knows it keeps
me going
that's great man so and do you do you go
uh you see right out in Brooklyn or do
you ride in Central Park like where do
you do your rides around here yeah it's
tough to ride around New York City yeah
um I I ride uh out in Rockaway beaches
where I live and uh so I'll ride into
Brooklyn to the Prospect Park area we'll
also come over the bridges I call it
like a four Bridge ride I do I'll come
over
from Rockaway to Brooklyn then from
Brooklyn to Manhattan then Manhattan to
New Jersey hit State Line in New Jersey
then come back and repeat for about 100
miles yeah nice
so but but getting into Central Park has
gone through some changes there's some
unfortunate accidents yeah you know
there's just a lot of people and
you know you really you really ha I'm
getting a lot of it done indoors now
right you know because I know plenty of
Pros
you can't get hit a third time out I'm
running out of lives yeah or you got to
move out to California
yeah I would love that I would love to
to take a journey one day and see what
it's like my wife was actually born in
San Diego oh yeah yeah well you could
use training camps yeah come on man
I I do I do get away to uh with a group
from that actually built my bike for me
because my bikes are custom made and um
I go to I've been to Mallorca three
times oh wow it's nice riding in Europe
is so different than right yeah it's
just
the the people you know the cars beep
the horn and to to wish you good luck
yeah the culture yeah it's the culture
yeah
well that's cool man uh let's I think
that's a good place to wrap it up and
close it down great I'm I'm uh super
stoked that you had me and it's pretty
awesome oh man are you kidding I'm so
glad that you came and did this uh
you're you know I'm sure you get fatigue
of hearing this but you are an
inspiration your story is extraordinary
and it really is a you know a beacon of
light for for so many people and uh and
I hope that you keep doing what you're
doing man and spreading your message are
you gonna write you're gonna write
another book thank you yeah I I don't
know you know we talk about it we I like
to be honest with you we're focusing on
making the book a movie oh cool man so
is there some activity behind that it's
been Division and stuff there's a little
activity yeah we have we have a guy in
California that's turning it into a
screenplay and he's shopping it around a
little bit it's very early and I could
never ever get done
um but he's pretty passionate about
getting it done and and I just said as
long as it could be done right and
Tastefully and if you really think that
it will further the message uh and he
believes it will so you know I it's my
story I wouldn't want to have a movie
about themselves you know of course man
I I still you know it you know what's
funny is I get a lot of
crap for my personality I just have one
of those personalities I can come across
to someone the first time I meet him as
his cocky son of a [ __ ] to have a man
or I just like to say to people that
I've always had a certain level of
confidence and
there's nothing wrong with it you know
so yeah I guess it'll be awesome you're
a New Yorker man I'm a New Yorker more
than Adam from Brooklyn
and what about the uh the what's going
on with the I will Foundation
yeah my foundation so you know the
foundation was birthed out of me saying
the words I will and
um I it to real and I can go real quick
with it is that
um I call the gentleman
um who I read an article about that was
hurt he's from Massachusetts Fabio
Slavic
um to this day I can't believe it I
still haven't met this guy but I got him
through the power of the internet we had
phone calls and I basically had them
please I said you know you hit
everything mirrored what happened
to me having to you
help me and I'll help others and he's
helped me tremendously and without
knowing I'm a perfect stranger and um
so I said I don't want
Fabio to be so hard to find for the next
mat long so I originally was going to be
a web page I will foundation not long
story you know take from what you can
and and go and then people started
sending me money you know I love it and
so now he started helping people so it's
it's small because it's me it's out of
my house
um any money I get I try to give right
to someone who needs help and we've
helped vets come home we've remodeled
kitchens and bathrooms for vets that are
now paralyzed I've I've taken a guy with
no arms built a bike for him and he rode
the bike from Florida to Spokane
Washington wow
he's now doing a big thing in Paris I
know I'm not going to know the name but
he's riding like 1200 miles in Paris wow
and um we helped a girl who was born
with polio be the first woman to
complete I am in Kona in a wheelchair
wow so it's it's just about getting in
there and helping him right away I don't
want it to become uh where I have a
building and where 30 go to expenses
it's like people write me letters and
unfortunately sometimes I have to say no
well people write me letters and say
this is what I want to if I'll give the
real quick story of this yeah yeah one
day I'm walking in now I'm moving out of
Manhattan my life is changing I'm
married and I'm looking for my bike shop
now I have bike shops in Manhattan so I
go into this bike shop in Sheepshead Bay
Roy's bike shop and I'm like oh yeah I'm
looking for this and this and that like
right and this gentleman comes in and
he's
talking about his bike and how it got
stolen and he kind of walks away and I
just being I guess that nosy New Yorker
I said to the guy behind the counter I
said what's what's the deal with this
guy
he's gonna
he lost his leg in a motorcycle accident
so I looked down and noticed that he was
an amputee
and uh he's kind of like in and out
living in like a shelter or something
and you know his bike was the only way
to get around and make some dollars we
gave him a bike and you know the staff
here we really can't do it again he left
it outside it got stolen
so I said
today's his lucky day I said here's 2500
hours
set them up and we bought we built
bought him a bike you know just helped
his individual that's a nice bike yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was the budget he
did get a nice bike he upgraded for sure
yeah
um but he got a 2500 bike and they put a
special pedal on it for his leg and and
it
that's something you can't do with a
bigger organization so that's the way I
want to keep the I will foundation so
it's there iwillfoundation.com my story
is there there's other people's stories
there it's not just about me and then we
try to help people that that have that
uh spirit to live yeah very cool and are
you are you speaking uh anytime soon
where the public can check you out like
what's the speaking schedule look like
or is that on your website mine um my
own website mattlongspeaker.com
um
we'll have events up but right now the
only two on the schedule are private
events right
um you know Marathon half marathon
season comes around usually I'm involved
with the road runners hopefully I'm back
with them so maybe at those events we'll
we'll be around right on all right so
people uh so people who want to check
out more about your story obviously the
book the long run you can find that on
Amazon click through the Amazon Banner
at richroll.com uh your website uh and
you're on Twitter Facebook all that kind
of stuff so
um Matt's long run that's long run
that's long run it's Matt's longrun.com
too right you have that site or that has
changed to Matt long speaker I made more
of a personal
so yeah cool man all right well thanks
so much for talking thanks for having me
I appreciate it man good to be back in
the neighborhood here cool yeah you need
to go over to Third and long now I'm
going to take a peek at the Old Third
and long you know old bar right see
what's going on right around the corner
cool man thanks all right thank you
peace
plants
[Music]
thank you